Rodney Harrison is here he will be part
of that monster pregame show from that
beautiful building that's right across
the street here in Minneapolis good to
see you sir and you have some hardware
on that right hand of yours from the
last time that the Patriots went
back-to-back by beating the Eagles and
then you were able to lift this trophy
what is that like lifting this trophy
Rodney Harrison well Tom had it in his
hands pretty much the entire time I
never got a chance to really pick it up
but I see it it's pretty special
what do you mean you never got a chance
to pick it up I never got a chance to
hope you want to do it yeah put them on
actually yeah you should do that because
the NFL doesn't use so Tom what do you
mean wise you're putting the gloves on
Tom kept it the entire time and and it's
like oh we won the Super Bowl it's all
about me it's all about me look at you
picking it up now is this the first time
you're picking up this trophy I think so
yeah I don't remember ever picking it up
yeah and that's something that you
definitely would remember picking up
would think it's beautiful so what was
that what was Bella checked like that
week coming in taking on an Eagles team
that had McNab taeo
and a chance to do what they have a
chance to do this week which is go
back-to-back his entire thing was just
stand patient making sure you do your
job making sure you take care of all the
little things but also making sure that
you take care of all the business the
week before making sure that you take
care of your tickets hotel rooms any of
that nonsense and letting your family
know that you're down here for a bigger
cost not to hang out with them not to go
to dinner those things are nice but
ultimately you're here to win a Super
Bowl so that's what he told you guys
like flat-out that was kind of a message
to tell your loved ones he's a lot nicer
now than he was back then yeah yeah yeah
he was very stubborn and very honoree
back then he's softened up recently
what's your indication that he's
softened up Rodney all you have to do is
go on to go into the Patriots
organization and kind of look around
it's just these guys have more freedom
which is good they have all these
personal meals and nutritionists we
never had anything like that
it was just strap on the helmet get out
there and take care of business so all
the stuff that apparently
sky was not allowed to be brought in was
brought in I'm trying to pick up what
you're putting down and trying enough
that's been reported yeah nothing to do
with Tom I'm just I'm just saying in
general but um as we speak about Tom
Thomas he's great and it was it's really
good to be able to communicate with him
I know he's really really focused on
this game and he wants to win this game
for his legacy so how what do you mean
for his legacy I mean did not hit me I
know does he think his legacy is not
cemented I think he looks at himself as
a six round draft choice and and he's
always looked at himself is that that's
why he prepares that's why he never
takes anything for granted that's why he
works his butt off and I tell you every
time I would go in there 5:30 6 o'clock
in the morning he's one of the first
guys in that weight room all right well
I want to take a break and then when we
come back dive into this game what you
think it's gonna happen at Super Sunday
if we can do that Rodney Harrison of NBC
Sports is here on the Rich Eisen show
live from Minneapolis in the Honda
studios all right we have a minute
before the radio audience returns how
you enjoying the paparazzi
I enjoy being part of the media Rodney
how you liking it I just got in rich and
literally I woke up and did a little
yoga this morning and came over here so
you never got a chance to do that I
never got a chance to do anything this
is my first thing no I'm just no I'm
just wrong in general being part of the
media oh you know in your second act of
your career I mean it's I'm enjoying I
get a chance I mean I love the Thursday
nights because you get a chance to go
out there on the field and talk to the
players and interact and it's it's nice
because as I've gotten older I'm 45 now
a lot of times I think that the younger
players don't know me and they'll walk
up to me and shake my hand hey mr.
Harrison love you know too what you used
to watch you play when you when I was
growing up and it was just really
surprising because I'm older now rich
and I'm closer to 50 come on now I can't
believe how many snaps could you give me
right now how many snaps Super Bowl I
probably give you about maybe about 10
to 15 snaps that's good I'll take that
I'll take that no nah man how many snaps
free to get your first flag how many
snaps
just whoever comes across the middle
when you're with Rodney Harrison back
when the radio audience returns in a
couple minutes you know how many times I
called them San Diego this year we all
did every last one of us so many times
you were just like oh yeah the San Diego
Chargers kept no chance this year and
they're like you're right because they
don't exist
screw that up MIDI Townsend tell we were
doing that all the time all right so now
you knowing the New England offense as
well as you do and Brady as well as you
do and knowing how talented these Eagles
are on defense as I'm sure you can agree
they're one of the top defenses in the
league this year how do they match up
well to prevent Brady doing what he
normally does in games like this I think
everyone has talked about it the
strength of their defense being in the
front floor and really taking advantage
of those offensive guards I mean I have
so much speed and quickness and they
don't have to blitz to create pressure I
think if you're the Patriots you're Tom
you expect that so the ball is gonna
come out quick I expect a lot of screens
a lot of hurry up offense just to change
a pace to keep those guys from rotating
all those different pass rushers okay
so how do you think Brady and the
Patriots and McDaniels are gonna combat
that well they're not gonna they're not
gonna do something that they've had
success for for 20-plus weeks and all of
a sudden go away from it I think the
best way is let put the ball in Tom
Brady's hands you don't have to worry
about snow you don't have to worry about
weather conditions and let him pass the
ball 40-plus times this front four and
and maybe the linebackers but I would
take a chance with my running backs
against those linebackers covering an
open space and attacking Darby and
jaylen mills and those guys I think Tom
Brady could throw over for 300 350 easy
on these what about foals against the
Patriots defense well I think it comes
down to discipline for the Patriots
defense because they have so many
different moving parts a lot of cross
boots play-action pass a lot of crossers
and things like that so if you're the
Patriots Matt Patricia saying hey number
one we have to make sure we read our and
trust our reads don't think that you see
something go up there and all of a
sudden you give up a deep play behind
you what do you mean by that trust your
reach well in that to people like my say
fans since if you have man-to-man on an
outside technique Belichick always told
us
I have you playing outside technique but
you get beat inside okay we live to see
another down but if I have you an
outside technique and you get beat
outside we got a real problem so that's
what I mean making sure that you do your
responsibilities and competing cuz in
and that's I'm pleased to have this
conversation because so many times when
I have a former Patriot sitting in a
chair like you Willie McGinest etc and
they just say well Belichick just tells
you to do your job and then it's just
like well okay how how does that
manifest itself there it is right there
that if your job is to play a certain
technique don't get beat on it period by
saying okay you got an outside technique
then think oh gosh I need to now play an
inside technique you get beat that's
when you get your ass chewed out I'll
give you an example at the early part
the first month of the season if you
remember Patriots gave up a lot of the
place they were historically and I'm
gonna tell you the difference back when
I play for Belichick he would have
benched one or two people in that
secondary but he was patient he allow
for a month for them to get it back and
then they became one of the best defense
that's why I say this is a different
Bill Belichick as opposed to when he
coached us or what about it wasn't as
deep as your team it wasn't as deep
maybe he just didn't think the other
options were were viable well they they
feel like they have a lot of debt
because they prepare all the backups
just as well as they prepare to saucers
because yeah Willie told us on gameday
morning when they were playing who were
they playing Tennessee with the exotic
Smash Mouth that you never know who's
gonna go get the ball goes I don't think
they're gonna have a problem with this
because if you do your job if you know
your assignment you don't follow all
that trickeration you just stay where
you are and just know what your readers
that's pretty much the way things go
what do you say it but when I look at
the page is defense I mean it's really
nothing in that front seven it really
impresses me I mean you look and you say
wow this defense is slow I went to the
AFC Championship game I left right
before half-time and I'm looking at that
defense and I'm like how are these guys
even here in the AFC championship game
and it's no disrespect because I spent
some time right after they won AFC
Championship but they don't have a lot
of great playmakers they don't have a
lot of great individual players on that
defense but what they have they have
guys that are coachable
guys that you if you tell them run
through that brick wall they're gonna
run a hundred miles per hour through
that brick wall and that's what
Belichick means
when he talks about not having the best
53 but having the right 53 players on
his team Rodney Harrison here on the
Rich Eisen show who on the Patriots
defense could crack the Eagle starting
lineup nondefense who on the Patriots
start defense would be able to crack the
Eagles starting lineup I want to say
probably their entire secondary their
entire second so is better than Jenkins
and Darby and although I would say
Jenkins is the wild card because Jenkins
can play Nicko he can play dad I'm back
where he's covered a tidy and he could
play deep safety free safety strong
safety but most of these teams are
playing with three safeties so when you
when you start talking about the for
starters actually is gonna be five
starters because Patrick chunk he plays
for own safety but he plays down in a
box so don't you think with the RPO is
that the Eagles are gonna just try and
pepper that that that five to ten yard
space beyond the line of scrimmage and
that's the way that they're gonna try
and move the ball down they're gonna try
to run they'll try to do those run-pass
option reads and all those different
things once again I don't know I'm not
the defensive coordinator you know I've
watched tape and I've seen the Patriots
and how vulnerable they are in certain
positions but if you're Philly you don't
it's not rocket science continue to do
what you've been doing run the ball
play-action pass let Nick Foles go I
love the fact that they allowed him to
be aggressive last week I sure did they
didn't micromanage him they didn't say
oh we're gonna treat you like your
rookie he is a grown man he's a veteran
he's won a lot of football games
continue to put the pressure on the
Patriots and you have a chance that's
the worst thing you could do because
everyone gets so enamored by the
Patriots and what Brady's doing and I
love the fact Doug Peterson said hey
it's not about the Patriots it's about
us
I'm not gonna talk about Belichick and
Brady we know what they've accomplished
and that's fine for them but we're here
to win a football game all our attention
goes on into us and I love that from
Doug Peterson when you were playing
against the Eagles and that Super Bowl
did you see McNabb in the huddle lose
his cookies did you guys see them
already knew McNabb I mean we respected
McNabb and we knew that he was a really
good player but we had such a great
defensive plan I think instead of
starting like three or four linemen we
started like five or six linebackers and
maybe one defensive tackle I think that
was Richard Seymour so we came out we
had five or six linebackers stand around
move
doing different things and it caught him
off guard but that was another genius
move by Bella check by putting so many
athletic guys in that we have more speed
on defense just tio belong in the Hall
of Fame tio is an absolute monster
and I don't care you know tio I'm not
one of his favorite people but I can say
as a football player he is a tremendous
football player he works hard he he
makes a lot of plays and there's no
reason why he shouldn't be a
first-ballot hall-of-famer
I'm actually embarrassed I'm sad
informed because if you can't if you
Terrell Owens and you can't get into the
Hall of Fame with what he's done on a
football field no one deserves a being
at them I think he deserves to be in it
this week in the minute we have left to
ask Rodney our poll question that's
sitting there on our app Apple App Store
Google player at the hit top of our
Twitter handle hit the link and you can
vote on this poll question go for it
Chris hey Rodney what's the worst of
team Bill Belichick Patriots have faced
in the Super Bowl the o3 Panthers eo4
Eagles Seahawks Falcons and this year's
eagle the worst one the worst one okay
you went negative hey you want negative
he went not so great okay well the
Panthers were probably the most physical
the Eagles were the cockiest well in a
close place with Seattle I think the
most gratifying victory was probably
when they beat Seattle when they that
was the most gratifying
he went positive you empowered negative
well last year we asked the best team in
this for askin the worst or you're just
into asking pissant questions being from
new way yeah that was a stupid question
maybe we should change it to be positive
B Rodney's tell us to be if you have a
positive question no have a great past I
believe it starts at noon Eastern Time
11 o'clock local here on Sunday on NBC
good to see you sir
thanks for coming thank you that's
Rodney Harrison Rich Eisen show weekdays
at noon eastern on audience